-The President is lying
about refugees
as he and his ex-national
security adviser, John Bolton,
argue over whether Bolton quit
or was fired.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
As we've established before,
Trump's entire political career
has been built
on racist conspiracy theories
about immigrants
and people of color.
Today, for example,
it was reported
that the Trump administration
won't give
temporary protective status
to people from the Bahamas
who fled Hurricane Dorian.
And when he was asked about that
on Monday, Trump said this.
-We have to be very careful.
Everybody needs
totally proper documentation
because, look, the Bahamas
has some tremendous problems
with people going to the Bahamas
that weren't
supposed to be there.
I don't want to allow people
that weren't supposed to be
in the Bahamas
to come into the United States,
including some very bad people
and some very bad gang members
and some very, very bad
drug dealers.
-I'm sorry.
So you think gang members
and drug dealers
snuck into the Bahamas
then hid out there
and waited for a hurricane
so they could eventually
pretend to be refugees
and sneak into
the United States.
"Psst! I need to get
this kilo of cocaine
into the United States."
"No problem.
Just take it to the Bahamas
and then wait five years."
The only people who have
ever been in the Bahamas
who weren't supposed to be
in the Bahamas
are old people
who got on the wrong cruise.
"I thought we were
going to Barbados!"
Trump has always conflated
immigrants with criminals
despite the fact
that immigrants commit crimes
at lower rates
than native-born Americans.
This is in many ways the central
lie of his political career,
and he repeated it again
during a rally on Monday,
even doing some crowd work with
the audience in North Carolina.
-One of the biggest issues
in this election
is, in fact, sanctuary cities.
Sanctuary-city policies
that force prisons and jails
to release criminal aliens
directly into
your neighborhoods.
"Get out. Go ahead.
Go into the neighborhood.
[ Crowd booing ]
Go into..."
What's your neighborhood?
Where do you live?
-Rutherford.
-What?
Rutherford County.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Okay.
So, how do you feel about
having them release
hardened, horrible criminals
into Rutherford County?
I don't think so.
-Oh, they're releasing
hardened criminals
into Rutherford County?
Are your aides on parole?
I mean, seriously.
Now...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now he's -- he's just
making up scary stories.
He should hold his rallies
in the dark
with a flashlight
under his face.
He's like a racist Stephen King.
"Where do you live? Maine?
How would you like it if they
released clowns into your sewers
that bit your arms off?"
In fact, Trump seems to be
getting more into crowd work
at his rallies
because after he had asked
people if they'd be cool
with fictional criminals
rampaging through their streets,
he polled the audience
on a very complex, esoteric
policy question,
a question that has vexed
and bedeviled
academics for centuries,
a question of such import
that it could very well define
Trump's presidency and this
country for decades to come.
-What do you like better?
"Made in America"
or "Made in the U.S.A."?
Go ahead.
Wait. Ready?
We'll go "Made in America."
Then "Made in the U.S.A."
What do you like better?
"Made in America"?
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Made in the U.S.A."
[ Loud cheers and applause ]
Okay.
-[ Chanting ] U.S.A.! U.S.A.!
U.S.A.! U.S.A.! U.S.A.! U.S.A.!
-So I think we know that answer.
-That might be
the single dumbest thing
I've ever seen in...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...in, uh...
Dumbest thing I've ever seen
in any arena,
and I'm including the time
the Toronto Raptors mascot
tried to skate down the stairs
and fell flat on his face.
[ Laughter ]
And, honestly, if at any point
this "Closer Look" bums you out,
just Google "mascot fails."
It's a lot of fun.
In fact,
at the end of this segment,
when it's time for me
to do my little wrap-up
summarizing how bad
everything is,
we're just going to put
some mascot fails
over my shoulder
to keep you entertained.
Before we do that,
that clip right there
really feels like
Trump in a nutshell.
False, performative patriotism,
pretending
he's making decisions,
when all he really cares about
is branding himself.
Before that rally,
he was probably up all night
trying to crack that one
like Mozart writing a symphony.
"Made in America? No?
Made in the United States? No.
Made in the U.S. of A?
Damn it, Donald.
You can do this!"
And the same empty symbolism
is the hallmark
of Trump's foreign policy.
During the campaign, he lied
and said he'd been against
the Iraq War from the beginning
but also called himself the most
militaristic person ever
and proclaimed his support
for a bunch of war crimes
including torture,
taking Iraq's oil,
and killing the families
of terrorists.
And, of course, he famously said
his main adviser on
foreign policy was himself
and that he got all his ideas
from watching television.
-Who do you talk to for
military advice right now?
-Well, I watch the shows.
I mean,
I really see a lot of great --
You know,
when you watch your show
and all of the other shows
and you have the generals
and you have certain people --
-But is there somebody --
Is there a go-to for you?
You know? Every presidential
candidate has a go-to.
-Probably there are
two or three.
-Since we have some dire
foreign-policy issues
percolating around the world
right now,
who are you consulting with
consistently
so that you're ready on day one?
-I'm speaking with myself,
number one,
because I have a very good brain
and I've said a lot of things.
-Oh, my gosh.
"I have a very good brain
and I've said a lot of things."
It sounds like they translated
rap lyrics into Japanese
and then back into English
with outdated software.
That sounds like
a tape recording
a psychological profile
would play during a trial
where the defendant
is pleading insanity.
"I heard the defendant having
a conversation in his cell,
and I asked him who
he was speaking with,
and he said this."
-I'm speaking with myself,
number one,
because I have a very good brain
and I've said a lot of things.
-"Defendant is legally insane.
Court adjourned."
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, Trump says he gets
his foreign-policy advice
from the shows, and, of course,
in particular he was talking
about Fox News.
That's where he saw John Bolton,
the former Bush administration
official and Fox News pundit
who Trump hired last year
as his third national security
adviser, which was horrifying
because Bolton is
an unrepentant warmonger
who has pushed for a regime
change in Iraq, Iran, Syria,
Venezuela, and North Korea.
In fact, a former Trump
administration official
actually told "The New Yorker,"
"John wants to bomb everyone."
And it's dangerous
to have someone like that
around Donald Trump because
Trump is very impressionable.
If Marilyn Manson
had a show on Fox News,
Trump would show up
to his next press conference
with jet black hair
and a nose ring.
It was always terrifying knowing
that an extremist neocon
like Bolton had the ear
of an impressionable president
who had no idea
what he was doing
and who took his advice
from TV pundits.
The relationship
was always weird.
And yesterday, it came to an end
when Trump fired Bolton.
Or maybe Bolton quit.
We don't really know
because, as usual, it happened
in the most chaotic way possible
with Trump tweeting about it
and Bolton texting reporters
while they were live on the air
reporting on his firing.
-Trump announced he'd fired
Bolton this morning on Twitter,
writing, "I informed John Bolton
last night
that his services are no longer
needed at the White House."
-We're just hearing
from Peter Baker
that John Bolton
has texted him, as well,
saying that he offered to resign
and resign today.
So that version
is differing very much
from the firing version
that comes from the President.
-John Bolton just texted me.
Just now. He's watching.
-Can you read it?
-Yeah.
He said,
"Let's be clear. I resigned."
And I said,
"Do you mind if I say that?
while you were talking,
and he wrote, "Yes."
So John Bolton has just told me,
texted me to say, "I resigned."
-This is insane.
They're all talking to each
other through the television.
Trump is firing people
via tweet,
Bolton is texting news anchors
on live TV to respond.
It's like if you were
watching a soap opera,
and in the soap opera,
one of the characters said,
"Oh, my God, John's evil twin
is at home watching this,
and he just texted me to say...
he's alive."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Today during a meeting
in the Oval Office
Trump was asked about
his decision to fire Bolton
and tried simultaneously
to criticize Bolton
for his extremist views
while also insisting
that he was tougher than Bolton,
but he also specifically and
repeatedly went out of his way
to criticize Bolton
for his role in the Iraq War.
-What led you
to decide to part ways?
-So, John is somebody
that I actually got along with
very well.
He made some very big mistakes,
and, frankly,
he wanted to do things
not necessarily tougher than me.
John's known as a tough guy.
He's so tough,
he got us into Iraq.
And, you know, John wasn't
in line with what we were doing,
and actually in some cases
he thought it was too tough
what we were doing.
Mr. Tough Guy. You know,
you have to go into Iraq.
Going into Iraq was something
that he felt
very strongly about.
So we're right now in
for over $7 trillion
into the Middle East.
But he was very out there,
I can tell you,
and wanting to have them do it.
I thought it was
a terrible mistake.
-If you knew all that then,
why did you hire him
in the first place?
This is like firing someone
for embezzlement
when they had "embezzlement"
under "special skills"
on their résumé.
Now, again,
it's absolutely a good thing
that an extremist warmonger
like Bolton is gone,
but it's also bad that he was
even hired in the first place.
So where does this leave us
as a nation?
Allow me to summarize.
Cue the mascot fails.
John Bolton
is an unrepentant warmonger
who was hired by a president
who has no consistent world view
when it comes to foreign policy,
or anything for that matter.
All he has are the racist
conspiracy theories
he concocts in his rotting brain
and the paranoid
right-wing media apparatus
that feeds him those theories
and then disseminates them
to his base.
Having Bolton in the White House
was a nightmare, but it's
just as terrifying to imagine
who Trump might hire next.
I mean, who knows?
If all he does is hire people
he sees on TV,
he might as well go ahead
and pick this guy.
[ Laughter ]
This has been "A Closer Look."